hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to explain the math behind why
you could multiply two numbers between
11 and 19 in your head
in the previous video we said if you
wanted to do 13 times 12 you could do a
series of steps where you added and
multiply different
portions of the numbers together to get
to the answer of 156
so we're going to go through the algebra
and see why this is actually a
legitimate method
a number between 11 and 19 can be
written as 10 plus x
where x is a number between 1 and 9.
so if we're multiplying two of these
numbers together
we have 10 plus x times 10 plus y
the first step of the process
was to take the entire number 10 plus x
and add it to the digit y
so we have
10 plus x plus y
to that result
we added a digit 0 which is the same as
multiplying by 10.
the second step of the process was to
take the units digits of both numbers x
and y
and multiply them together
so that would give us x y
the final step was to add these together
so doing some algebra
the first step would give us 100 plus 10
times the quantity x plus y
and the second step in green
gives us x times y
so this is the algebraic result of our
process
and if you check the math this is
exactly what you get by expanding the
two terms 10 plus x times 10 plus y
so in fact our three-step process
will give us the correct answer
i hope you liked this video please
subscribe to my channel
you can also catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions or on twitter at
preshtalwalker